que recibió a inmigrantes como mis
abuelos un símbolo de la libertad y un
icono de esperanza para el mundo hoy
todo ha dividido a nuestro país ha
disminuido nuestra grandeza y todo lo
que representa esta estatua del atrás
mismo incluso se escondió en un búnker
mientras que golpeaban y retiraban los
manifestantes
170 mil personas han muerto por kobe y
dicen que esto es lo que es un
presidente nunca debería decir algo así
el presidente lincoln honrando los
grandes sacrificios de kris boyd no dijo
esto que es el presidente roosevelt
yendo a un tercio de la nación en
problemas no dijo esto es lo que es eeuu
donald trump
no les ha cumplido necesitamos un
presidente con integridad y con
experiencia para liberarnos y sacarnos
de la crisis es un hombre con una mano
firme y con un corazón grande que nunca
vaya
en cumplirle eeuu esa persona es yo
bailé será un gran presidente pero si
vamos a ganar esta batalla por la por el
alma esta nación no puede hacerlo solo
los demócratas deben retomar el senado
vamos a mantenernos unidos desde sanders
y martín a mancini y warner y con
nuestra unidad vamos a llevar un cambio
audaz y dramático a este país y les diré
algo de las cosas que haremos con el
presidente vaivén y la vicepresidenta
harris y una mayoría demócrata haremos
que la salud sea asequible para todos
acabaremos con la inequidad de los
salarios que ha plagado tanto este país
desde hace tanto tiempo si tomaremos
acción decisiva para combatir el cambio
climático y salvar el planeta vamos a
proteger los derechos de votaciones en
luchar contra él
racismo sistémico y vamos a restaurar
una corte suprema que busque apoyar a la
gente y no las corporaciones vamos a
reconstruir nuestra infraestructura y
asegurarnos que cada hogar desde las
ciudades hasta eeuu rural sea restaurada
salvaremos el servicio postal de una vez
por todas y vamos a derrotar al kobe 19
esta enfermedad y según ésta está todo
detrás mío vamos a reformar nuestros
sistemas de inmigración para que los
inmigrantes que quieren ser libres
finalmente puedan convertirse en
ciudadanos juntos vamos a darle nueva
vida a esas esperanzas a las masas
aquellos que vieron a esta gran mujer
con su torta sabiendo que podían
construir una mejor vida aquí en este
país
y después de esta gran pesadilla eeuu
finalmente se despertará lucha un futuro
más brillante y un nuevo día